Let's see.
Let's go next to let's go to our caller from
the 774 who I have noted as a woman from Massachusetts
or Rhode Island.
Does that make sense?
77 some Ford.
You know who that is?
Yes, I mean, that is exactly what was your
name for some reason, we didn't get it last
time.
Jen.
Okay, what's on your mind, Jen?
Yeah, I was living on the border, so I still
have a magic number, but I'm actually in Providence
now.
Okay, that's allowed.
Now, Jen, you're coming in so hot.
Please try to keep the phone just a little
further from your mouth and you'll will be
able to he'll hear you much more perfectly.
All right, it is better.
Oh, my God, that's so much better.
Thank you.
OK.
Thanks.
So do you know anyone who worked for the census
this year as a numerator or anything?
Not personally, but I've had them come to
my house.
OK, so I did.
I was in enumerator for three weeks and there
might be some cause for concern.
Coming up in the next 10 years with the results.
Yes, this was a complete mess.
Yes, I did it 10 years ago.
And, of course, it was a much different political
climate than what it is now.
Right.
But this was horrible.
They tried a completely new system.
They tried doing it all by smartphone and
it was constantly giving us errors.
It would just drop us from time to time.
It would send us to completely wrong neighborhoods.
And there were just a lot of people who did
not want to be counted or people who you would
answer the door and they would be crying,
finding out a family member just got covered.
Oh, my God.
We're coming face to face with the virus.
And like, oh, crap.
Did they have it?
Did they breathe on me, you know, things like
that.
Now, let me ask you this job.
John, let me ask you this.
When someone didn't want to be counted, what
was their explanation?
Why why would what did they say?
A lot of times we would lie and claim they
did it online or sinta to their mouths.
I. I can understand with what's going on.
But if they did it online, it would have been
coming up.
A few people did get flat out aggressive and
said they don't want Trump knowing their business,
that they don't think.
We need to know also why Providence is a very
ethnically diverse area.
A lot of Hispanic residents and they thought
that that citizenship question was right on
there.
Right.
Right, right.
They were terrified that we were going to
start asking them about that.
And they didn't know that, did they?
Did in part.
So that's interesting.
You're not even answering the door.
That's interesting, because I previously said
once the citizenship question was thrown out,
that the damage may well have been done merely
by proposing it and that it may not even get
to people that it was thrown out.
And it sounds like you're saying that's exactly
what happened.
Yes, we definitely had the repercussions of
that.
As soon as they talked about it, I just thought,
oh, man, I wanted to do it this year, it's
going to be a mess.
And it was even worse than what we expected.
Do you think that you received adequate training
for doing this during a pandemic, or were
you just kind of thrown to the wolves?
We were pretty much thrown to the wolves because
they couldn't really do any in-person training.
They had a few online videos.
They had us watch.
Wow.
But for the most part, the phone system would
kind of walk you through it.
But when it was constantly just kind of tripping
over itself, it was just causing more and
more problems.
And at one point, they just started dropping
people because we had too many, like do not
answers and things like that where they're
like, yeah, you know, if you're assigned neighborhoods
have gone stale.
We have no more need for you.
Goodbye.
Well, I wish I could say.
Hundred ninety dollars.
Gee, I wish I could say what you were telling
me was surprising, but we've been talking
about this for the last four years, that this
is exactly how the census was going to go.
And Janet, sounds like it's going exactly
that poorly.
Yes.
So there's going to be some bad blow out from
it in the next few years.
You know all the results, because there's
going to be representative that we're not
going to get schooled, that we don't get here,
all because, you know, all these tens of thousands
of people who were not counted.
Right.
All right, Jen, thank you.
Thank you for letting us know what's going
on.
I wish you had better news.
Thank you, David.
You have a great day.
All right, you too.
Take care.
There's a Jen from the epicenter of the border
between Massachusetts and Rhode Island.